previously a nightmare of Decay you turn
around and see a large man staring at
you with a gray smile on his face and
the next moment the man Fades away just
as suddenly as he appeared okay that's
weird oh god oh yes my freaking head to
agree to it strangely enough you can
understand what he's saying
looks like the nightmare is claimed yet
another victim hi hello are you no no no
no no no click click
okay well you need to find a key
apparently
oh no malicious presence
oh God that's not what I expected or
there's got to be this
no
don't know
well uh uh save me the trouble of
headbutting you because uh that would
have been a death sentence as well so
why did you leave behind
as soon as I know great to my dearest
Lucy I know that this letter will
probably never reach you but I had to at
least leave something behind if only to
give me a peace of mind before I do what
must be done I don't know how many days
or even weeks it's been since I've been
trapped in this horrid place I remember
falling asleep beside you only to wake
up in a nightmare
a nightmare of Decay
as I sit here and prepare to take my own
life I wonder if I will finally awaken
to find myself next to you in bed or if
I will enter my eternal sleep never to
see you again I love you Lucy pray for
me
all right well I am just a little bit
behind events here but I got a magnum
you cannot argue with that but I don't
have Magnum ammo I don't think anyway
think anyway
[Music]
I don't know why I keep getting the
Pelican here I don't know why I keep
hanging it around
um did you even have any
ammo he killed himself
I'm an incredible detective
Case Closed okay what key did I get
cabin oh
excellent I'll never know like this is
just a damn Delight it really is it's
like such a change of place from normal
horror games that I play that was just
like walk through this building
[Music]
admittedly I have made it that way or
lyxian has made it that way
come on lexian what were you thinking
don't put this on me no no no no no no
no I know you and you know you and we
know you you love a jump scare you're
probably gonna hit them with one right
now
and in the cabin we go
I'm sure some
you gonna shoot yourself
hello
hi drunken man you see a drunken man
drinking from a bottle his eyes are
sunken in and there's a haunted tired
look on his face what
uh-huh yeah I see that this horrible
places
before you ask I have no idea what this
place is or how I got here I'm probably
the same as you woke up air after going
to sleep
after getting chased by some rabid dogs
I managed to escape into this cabin and
lock myself in imagine my surprise to
discover that the cabin was filled with
boxes of booze
if I'm gonna meet my end in this place I
definitely don't want to be sober when
it happens
someone tried to get inside earlier was
slamming the door begging to be let in I
ignored him no way I was gonna open that
door with all those monsters outside
pretty sure the dogs got him
the horrid screams as they ripped him
apart like a squealing pig mixed with a
grind baby something I'll never be able
to forget I'm probably next at least I
have this booze to keep me company
before I die yeah not me I guess
yeah
you could talk to me but you know
something tells me you're not good
company all right did you forget
something in this room something
horrible in here
whoa you forgot about the crap
[Applause]
oh okay okay
well
that's what I thought
I don't know why I told you to cue the
music and then I did the music but make
it better than what I did please
uh
uh interesting take one of these got him
I think I think I think I got him
I think I did
take cover
too bad you're terrible shots
come out here got him right in the dome
oh I'm good God damn only took a few
shotgun pellets in that cabin and then I
got a hexagon everyone knows what to do
with this give me that give me that you
don't deserve it you don't deserve it
until you can head and bought your first
kill
what was that whoa whoa what was that
I was being sassy and you're gonna
interrupt me but the figment of my own
imagination either way I got the cranks
uh which was I believe over this way the
room of knights which might have been to
the right here I'm not 100 sure I don't
think so
I was right I was right oh I'm the best
I'm the best oh ah
okay so that's how you turn that so then
this must be it must oh I see what this
does I bet is this pushes using that
indentation right there
and then boom and then I can use that to
turn it on
the platform it is almost too perfect
love that love this for me love all of
this for me it really flows well I gotta
say
most of the time I feel like I'm just
stupid and I don't know what I'm doing
which you know is true but at the same
time
I feel like I'm actually getting this my
brain is firing at full capacity oh
[Music]
yeah dude
I did it I'll take that Crown clearly
this means that I can govern you people
I'll see you around I gotta go put a
crown on a bust
hello I'm gonna defeat your friends
subjects
friends oh
don't do it oh you did it
okay
he's in oh God okay oh
[Laughter]
God he's got a bow
okay this is going well so far oh God I
gotta run run run run run run run run
run get some distance
okay oh God they did not stop oh God
okay wait hold your horses
if you have them you are a night after
all whoopsies okay I need to reload but
I know it's gonna oh hey how's it going
there pal hello everybody hello
all right can you not oh please okay
almost dead Okay one's down and your
next buddy
buddy yeah that's what I thought all
right I'm gonna take this guy out of
range
foreign
you're really pathetic without your
friends you don't even shoot a bow
you're petrified
I might come up and stab you
oh well I thought I might give you a
Fighting Chance
you don't think you can dance your way
out of this one nice try pal nice try
I'm way too smart for that and way too
bloodthirsty and way too handsome can I
take the crown back
all right fine doesn't this seem a
little
I didn't seem a little high-tech to have
an elevator in here with this kind of
like King's dungeon aesthetic
but I guess I shouldn't question it
I don't have aesthetic anyway
well we finally moved into the new Manor
Irma was against it but I finally
managed to convince her I'm sure she'll
fall in love with this place in no time
at all it also helped that the price for
the manor was Dirt Cheap something about
horrific murder something about horrific
murders in the past and it being uh
haunted but I don't care I was drawn to
this manner for the First mom and I laid
eyes on it almost as if it was
calling to me yeah me too me too me too
me samsies actually samsies all right
where am I
glug where am I
a zombie oh
man that was close
oh no oh zombie
oh oh yeah there you go what is that all
about
right cut the chains or something like
this yeah yeah all right never mind then
I guess I'm not that strong
because I'm just pathetic
stop stop stop stop stop
is that dog that dog that dog I don't
want to have to shoot a dog again but I
will if I have to it's already rabid
needs to be put down
oh boy here we go
I got my reload preemptively here watch
this this is how smart I am this is how
smart is that smart smart smart
oh I feel terrible
I feel terrible I have him there oh I
feel terrible
I'm sad now
I'm sad oh God it could have been me oh
that's another one of these huh
what is with these bloody wardrobes and
being locked is there a bloody wardrobe
key specifically you got a key on you up
your ass anywhere
why is it why oh wait that's the
Wardrobe in the basement that's the
special wardrobe that actually is a big
deal probably maybe I don't really know
but I think it is anyway
oh God another zombie
can I pick it up okay cool
Wham look out
[Music]
[Applause]
all right old man
whatever okay this is back to the
beginning that was a big waste of time
and now this is where I need to be I can
feel it in my bones
oh goopy
all right Wham
okie dokie
lock from the other side huh this might
be one big loop which might mean I have
to run away from something into Loop but
I don't know
I bet this Loops I bet this loops
oh it's a furnace I thought it was
something scary okay don't want to go
down the ladder yet until I know why
that's gross stuck bolt cutters
there may be some way to dissolve the
growth I don't have any more of that um
I don't have any more of that uh acid
I've got Dynamite that could work I
could blast it oh
this is why I kept the pellet gun right
here oh yeah headshots are doubled at
time extended I love that oh frick here
we go baby let's do this
I'm ready
Wham
oh really oh
oh yeah oh yeah
oh man I'm so glad I got this pellet gun
God damn
oh I missed it well I wouldn't have had
time anyway it's all good it'll come
back around how many points did I need
I feel like I might be getting close
250 never mind not as close as I thought
foreign
well I might as well see what I can do
is probably it
oh come on
oh be all right 455 not bad I kind of
flubbed it at the end there but I'll
take it not the worst not the worst I'll
take it give me give me give me and
Magnum ammo is that really all I got
they didn't have any story important
stuff here well fine then I guess I'm
just amazing I guess I'm just incredible
but I don't have anything to possibly
help me with that okay but I can go down
into them wherever this leads then is
something I can do oh great good
Magnum is charged delay before firing
hold left to charge charge
it does it does it actually do you think
it does it's a gun I don't know if it do
go but freaking got him
where'd you go Cotton Eye Joe
[Applause]
what were you okay
will you be oh he's embarrassed yeah he
should be that was pathetic and pitiful
and childish
um and cringe don't forget about cringe
Prince hello
hi what's going on here more sewer great
hello what's gonna pop up out of the
water oh almost missed you
all right that's so far so good
[Music]
all right so far so good
hey
all right never mind then
I take back everything I said
oh yeah there was a goodie in here so
I'm gonna go there it is all right not
doing too good on ammo I've really
chewed through a lot of it in this uh
like climb between PLA that's it
radioactive I shouldn't touch it I'm
gonna touch it I'm going to touch it
yes are you sure it's just acid it looks
very Radioactive
all right here we go I don't know of any
acid that glows but
I'll take it my dude
I'll take it
I almost drank the jar of acid I would
have been able to handle it but might
have been devastating to someone of a
weaker Constitution
wow
oh God I wasted my chance where am I
probably goes to the loopback it
probably opens up that door that was
there before you save thank you
and then joinkus oh really but I don't
have it but I don't have the thing ah it
was probably like right around the
corner I'm dumb that's right because I
just literally popped out into the sewer
just to do that so of course it would be
right there and then I would come back
around and then I bet there's goodies on
the other side of that door because it
wouldn't just be a wrap around because
that's that would be too simple
I'm gonna come back for that and there's
gonna be goodies there and you can count
on that because I guarantee it
100 definitely going to be goodies here
thank you joink I'll take that and I'm
going down here again
and then I'm gonna get some
although I do feel like I can shoot
bolts but it's a Resident Evil logic
where you can't do it without
specifically a bolt cutter everything in
the universe has a purpose and if it
does get used for that purpose it can't
be used for anything else we all know
this except for a headbutt that is
universal for everything solves all of
life's problems all right now I'm gonna
save save over that dumb save
grow bar would that work what is a
crowbar for oh it's a melee weapon like
Half-Life oh my freaking God all right
hell yeah no that's a
that's something more my speed oh yeah
pretty good
oh was it oh wait where am I actually
whoa what is this all about
what do we have going on here ooh
something tells me that I shouldn't go
down there just yet because it seems
like some kind of an arena to fight with
oh this is the wrap around okay
I'm going in the arena to fight I get it
I see when I'm needed downstairs and I'm
needed downstairs right now
sure I hope this doesn't break on Me Oh
I thought it was gonna oh
there it goes
called it
oh
well
good thing I got a ladder
[Music]
that is very Cry of Fear that reminds me
of CR oh my God that straight up Cry of
Fear
oh God chainsaw psycho oh God hello oh
ow oh I'm dead
yep turns out I'm dead Okay um let's
think about this a little bit uh let's
use the Magnum
that sounds pretty good I'll do that
skip this take one of these bang oh that
that does put a stop to you but uh what
do I do about it it's got to be
something with this right yeah okay I
bet I I'm gonna get him down on the
ground oh we have something in his back
I saw it okay you come here
[Music]
okay and then I'm gonna shoot this oh I
bet if I shoot that anyway
okay I shouldn't I shouldn't waste that
that's okay this is this is good though
this isn't a this is a reason to
stun him
and then basically ow okay but that's
fine
oh yeah and then you're done you're done
you're done shouldn't have even like
given up a chance for you but whatever
can I get that can I have that can I
have that can I say mine now can I have
that can I have that can I have that can
that be mine that that should be that
kind of
foreign
whatever
oh God that scared me all right what do
we got here Boop and bloody wardrobe key
just for me before I do uh anything I'm
gonna actually go back and save here
because I don't even know where the
other save is I bet it's right around
the corner but I have a funny feeling
when I go in this bloody wardrobe I
might get to some kind of an ending here
because I feel like this is the bloody
wardrobe at the bottom and and that guy
that I just killed seemed like he might
have been a boss of some kind the one
that I saw in my original Vision to chop
the heads off of various people but
let's see let's see what the deal is
let's see
hello
how are you
what are you up to
can I help you
oh okay all right
oh wait wow okay all right
is the body of an insane woman even in
death you have a manic smile you
remember the creature wanted female
heads take her head
[Music]
all right you know I don't need to
follow that one
I feel like doing that would be a
terrible idea I feel like that's how you
end up like a her so I'm gonna just you
know not do that right now unless I have
to and then I will do that but not right
now
yippee
this is my whole
hole why do I want to go in a hole I
don't really know I don't know I don't
know I don't know hi welcome
me
oh
hi hello how are you hello again
stranger I didn't think you would make
it this far you're tougher than I
thought or maybe just lucky
either way I don't think you'd be able
to survive for much longer down here in
the dungeons some truly monstrous beasts
lurk down here and I'm pretty sure one
of them will get you good luck stranger
you'll need it
okay
some people said this was a short
experience I mean I guess comparatively
to short I've uncovered a large
man-sized hole in the wall in the
basement I crawled through the hole and
was astonished to discover a massive
underground dungeon on the other side
the dungeon may be thousands of years
old and I can just imagine the ancient
Treasures that lay within I've ordered
the surface to cover up the hole with a
wardrobe and watch them as they work to
make sure none of them got curious and
crawled through no one else knows about
the dungeon and I plan to keep it that
way
did you
did you kill the did you do you kill
them
hello
love the Dead Space reference but also
that's oh man you are happy that's my
technique
uh back off
hello
uh you're naked
hello
damn it
here
[Music]
[Music]
when you say Mass
shoot he's all around you'd be able to
get him in almost instantly
wow
oh so close
so close
and yet so far huh I'll be taking
I said well never mind then
I was going to be taking that but
whatever
Lord's Diaries how many days has been
since I discovered this dungeon I don't
remember anymore or masked me about what
I've been doing in the basement but
there's no way I'll tell her I won't
tell anybody this is my secret alone
something calls to me down here and I
won't rest until I find it
I won't rest either I suppose
is that for me you've been shot to death
it's one way of putting it actually it's
very accurate way of putting it hello
circular slot no way there's more slots
Epic there's more uh pegs
killer
oh Jesus Jesus Christ Jesus Christ oh my
God
you weren't kidding when you said truly
monstrous things lurk down here
I'd rather kill this than a freaking dog
butero
people
I'd love to be in on the joke I love
laughing
Jesus Christ
holy [ __ ]
oh my God all right
probably a lot of secret ammo that I
haven't been finding around here that's
like tucked into Corners that I've never
gone into but alas not for me I'll just
have to make do without what am I doing
now oh
ero
[Music]
interesting am I locked in here with you
or are you oh
oh you couldn't have shot one time in
that direction oh boy here we go
how uh how bad oh very bad
ah I'm gooped
oh god oh no this is bad okay wait no
it's fine boom Shaboom okay
man I wish I had my freaking knife not
this [ __ ]
okay watch this oh yeah that's how I do
whoops what did I do no no no no no no
no maybe I should have my knife nah I'm
going with this because I'm gonna do
this to you boom that's what you get
oh God
oh God this is not good
no not that wait where's my Magnum there
it is
there we go now you're dead
give me more magnum bullets but that was
a I didn't expect to have that here and
now hi you all right very happy
very happy
okay I'm gonna take this whatever it is
I think it's probably good for me
okay so I got a big silver disc but why
why do I have this and why did I need
this I don't understand anything that's
happening anymore
I've kind of lost the plot a little bit
but that's okay because I still have my
gun and my crowbar and with them I will
be able to do some damage
uh uh circular slot oh it's not a peg oh
it's not a peg it's a literally it is a
circular slot that I put this into isn't
it is it not is it is is it silver disc
yes it is it is ah interesting good good
golden tablet
Don't Mind If I Do
I will can I not have that wait
can I not take it back what was that a
one-time use
that couldn't have been a one-time use
how is that going to be a one-time use
there's something over here oh
did that have a silver well that's got a
golden tablet in it
but I did see mag I don't understand any
of this I don't understand anything
that's going on but I'm gonna plow
forward as if I do because I'm committed
to the bid at this point and I must be
because otherwise I would be completely
wasting my time and I'm not about that
I'm not about that at all
I might be about that a little
considering I've been playing this for
like an hour and a half and I thought it
was going to be like an hour game and I
would be in and out but it's not not
that I'm complaining I'm not complaining
I'm not complaining at all it is still
fun but I'm confused
hello
neither thought you could hide for me I
thought you could have for me I bet
there's been tons more secrets that I
haven't seen that just makes me mad I've
not seen some secrets
oh well nothing a shotgun can fix I had
a key for that apparently didn't even
realize it hi diddly ho ho anybody want
to get shot
anybody need a golden tablet I have one
whoa no I'm gonna run I don't think I
need to kill you guys why would I you're
so slow what would it matter anyway
excuse me yeah I know I know
uh-huh wait wait
that's supposed to kill you
oh oh my God that's not good oh your
head's gone are you dead nope okay you
dead
oh boy
you dead
oh you just reached oh oh oh
ah I don't like that okay get please
leave oh no no no no no no no no not
like this no you will die get out of the
way out of the way out of the way out of
the way out of the way out of the way
out of the way out of the way no you are
I don't know
you son of a [ __ ] you got my way I was
out of a shotgun at the wrong time I
should have just kept going I should
have known that you were just gonna be a
thing that you were gonna
I'm making a break for it
[Music]
excuse
[Applause]
me pardon me
Amy
pardon me
you're burden me
excuse me
don't get in my way again
oh you're just I think that one's just
like a tougher one by Design just to get
in your way just to get in your way a
little bit
oh God that's not good that's not what
you like to see oh get off of me no no
no no I like this not like this oh boy
oh no not like this oh yes like this
like this like this okay here we go
there we go that's what we love that's
what I'm talking about that's what we're
doing
don't what did you just do did you just
regener your arm who took your arm
who took his arm I don't even know who
took his arm did I get what I need
mass murder at haunted Manor Irma heard
Shaw wife prominent businessman William
herja and their many live instruments
have been found murdered in a manner
known to locals as being haunted bodies
of the servants were brutally mutilated
and murmured her cha was found
decapitated in her bed William her child
the main suspect of the Titans crime has
gone missing and is believed to be on
the Run uh turns out he was here the
whole time
turns out he was here the whole time did
I get everything I needed down there did
I get anything I needed down there I
don't think I did I don't think I
grabbed a single goddamn thing that I
needed
if there was anything that I needed down
here
which I don't know if that is true
this way
oh you know where I'm going is this
right this feels right this feels right
hey silver disc
and another one which means I'll have
two golden discs
but why do I would I need them ah
goodbye I've got two silver discs now so
I'm gonna go get the other thing and
then I'll have two building tablets and
then it should be good and then I go
home and then I've got two golden
tablets and I've got all the riches a
man could want a squad
all right and give blogs chug where's
wug all right so that gave me nothing oh
you gave me golden tablets that's what I
needed that's what I came here for so
but I don't remember seeing a place for
Golden tablets
is there a place for Golden tablets I
haven't seen a place for Golden tablets
and I've been pretty much everywhere
here in this place I have another bloody
wardrobe key and technically speaking I
could do the head fetch I'm not really
too happy about the head fetch but it
seems like I might have to do the head
fetch I do know technically of where I
could find three at this point if I
really really wanted to which I guess
I'm going to have to so uh
yeah
hello again please don't mind me just
gonna oink okay got that nothing strange
there
just a man with two golden tablets in a
pocket full of Dreams
all right well that was a good time that
was a good time that was a good time
good time good times good times I'm a go
uh chop off another one I had such a
good time with that head I thought oh
man
two you ever think of that you just get
ooh satisfied with one head not me
anyway hey you know how I stole that
coin for me or whatever
hey don't mind me
yep all right goodbye I'm sure there
won't be any repercussions for this and
then the last head would be in another
bloody wardrobe that I just so happen to
have a key to here yes here
bloody wardrobe key it's the same
oh hi hi chainsaw psycho didn't I kill
you Hi how are you it's a crazy psycho
with a chainsaw that attacked you in the
basement he's peering at you from inside
the bloody wardrobe with a manic smile
on his face he doesn't seem to be
hostile at the moment good for me
oink thanks pal
all right anyway
you want round two I'll meet you anytime
anywhere you remember this bad boy you
remember this why don't you just come on
back if you want to feel the Thunder
again right all right pellet gun haha
blink okay
all right I have three heads uh who
wanted three heads this was on the other
side it was the guy that wanted the
heads was on the other side and the club
room over in Yonder way
I think wasn't it the club room over
here wasn't Club room man Club room
Club room
all right uh you uh
here you go
excellent you brought me three beautiful
female heads please wait a moment while
I fetch you your reward
thanks
thank you for the ads please enjoy your
reward
oh wow
wait you're telling me that
tell me that it wasn't I didn't actually
that wasn't you tell me that I I didn't
actually I did it
all right so what are the golden tablets
for the holy water Divine explosion that
sounds pretty cool I gotta remember what
was basically down here like I don't
know how that's gonna help me very much
but you know I haven't now but I have
these golden tablets there has to be
something down here that this is
important for why else would they give
it to me right the golden tablets two of
them it was a task to get two of them
they're
foreign
okay so there's got to be a place where
these golden tablets are used but I
don't think I've seen it yet it might
still be in the basement
I'm just not 100 sure where it's it's
somewhere in there I had to look up um
some kind of indication of where it
would be it's it's in the bottom which
makes sense because now that I'm
thinking about it it does make sense but
I just am unsure of where I'm supposed
to use these golden tablets but there's
got to be some down here it's not in the
loop-de-loop it's got to be something
over here that I've missed that I
haven't seen and for some reason I'm
unable to peer into the darkness enough
to be able to see it and I don't know
why
because it should be easy
I'm really good at games
uh someone some here is oh no
It's gotta be
was was this all was
no come on
come on
oh God
it was right there the whole time oh
okay are you okay are you gonna kill me
how are you you see a heavily wounded
man laying against the wall he's barely
clinging to life this isn't me that's my
first bees in the games behind that door
I tried to escape from it who's too fast
if you see it don't try to fight it just
run run from the Beast ah he's dead
okay
um so are you serious about that just
run I am all about that actually I'm 100
okay with that
what do I do
oh god oh what do I do
what do I do
oh hey uh uh no okay that's fine I can't
run from that why would I run from that
whoa oh hey hey are you the monster
you're not the monsters Beast are you
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say that
you're not the Monstrous Beast and the
Monstrous Beast is lurking somewhere
down here okay
foreign
[Music]
let's try to do one of these moves I
haven't done this ever
yo yeah that's what I thought about that
oh yeah
come on oh there we go he uh died
nothing could be done about it
all right so it's gotta be a big beastie
a big old Beast down here somewhere
anybody want to say hi
that's a skeleton these are a skeleton
are you serious
oh my God
oh God they're quick oh how'd they know
how'd they know
oh [ __ ] he's got a shield oh
drop your Shield ow
oops
peekaboo
all right so that didn't go perfectly
well for me but they're still dead they
were dead but now they're deader and I'm
a liver a drink I also have holy water
which I'm sure will work on something
terrible down here terrible oh who has
time for this oh I do
thank you
better than wasting 10 bullets on you
play that much
okay so it's a terrible thing down here
big bad terrible thing do I just run
this is where I run right this is where
I run this is where I run this is where
I run I'm just going
okay
oh no no
no oh no
no
no
no
oh God
how do I get away from this if the I
haven't saved in a while oh God no
oh God no I'm running for my life I'm
running for my life oh God I'm exhausted
oh no oh no holy water I have holy water
could that work
might that be enough
where do I get a key for this [ __ ] ah I
am freaking out of here there's no way
there's no way uh-uh no way yeah oh my
God
please no I'm exhausted oh God not now
I'm so close to the end please have
mercy on me
oh
that was too close chump maybe you gotta
get good they gotta stop being bad maybe
you gotta get better in life and then
love and lust maybe you could get better
at all the above [ __ ]
Wham don't ask me what that means
because I even I don't know what that
means I really don't know what that
means Wham got it I'm the best how about
one of these bad boys Wham
and lo and behold the mystery of the
deep has been solved by me and not
someone who got their wife murdered by a
chainsaw wielding Maniac I'm the best he
has
an ooh family hey look at this this
looks like preparation no I'm sure it's
fine everyone must die
say no more my bro say no more everyone
must die and I shall lead them hit him
with the jump boom good thank you I just
don't get the blood going now cue up the
non-stop Doom music because it's time to
go blasting uh we're gonna start off
with some holy water bear now
I meant
well this is underwhelming I thought
there was going to be a thing here
oh it's a thing
down here
oh miss me [ __ ] take that all right how
about you want some dynamite oh what's
this dynamite oh [ __ ]
wait can you oh that's what I thought
and here's one of these oh dynoma ow
Dynamite all right
all right uh one of these please oh God
ow come on these
well he's dead
that's what I thought about that that's
what I thought bit get jump scared
oh
I thought it was a phase two might not
be
I remember when I ate pizza
so long ago
what a day that was when I got pizza
what a terrible die bear you're covered
in sweating your heart is thundering in
your chest as you get up from your bed
it's still the middle of the night and
it will be some time before the sun
rises but you don't feel like going back
to sleep
not after that
horrific nightmare
maybe a short walk outside and some
fresh air will help calm you down
right
maybe a game
can I save
[Music]
D I can go outside
oh Kitty I knew you'd be here to talk to
me how are you
hello
uh-huh
sure okay oh no
oh no
hello hello again stranger did you
really think you could escape from The
Nightmare well it's like I said in the
beginning no one ever escapes alive
[Music]
oh
Kitty
oh boy
I'm dead
you have awakened from The Nightmare
but the real nightmare has just begun
I did it yay awesome extra modes [ __ ]
yeah bruh what do we got horde mode
don't just Escape oh sick disabled
this does this disable all cultists in
the world before I press a button did I
complete my objective be awesome kick
ass chew gum
yep uh go check out distractible link is
in the description for that and also if
you haven't watched in space with
markiplier yet why haven't you I work so
hard on that everyone works so hard on
that it's a great show
which I'm gonna disable all the cultists
now I don't know what's gonna happen
when this gets clicked but I'll see you
on the other side
foreign
[Music]